[Musique]
soit
marie c'est via ses lambaye habite
depuis cinq ans le logement social à
saint-andré et depuis le début de
l'année cette mère de famille est
désormais propriétaire de cette petite
case une opportunité qui s'est
concrétisé en partie grâce à l'aide
départementale à l'accession à la
propriété des locataires du parc locatif
social
elle a ainsi bénéficié d'une subvention
d'un montant de six mille euros
manquaient des sous mais l'aide du
conseil général a été très bénéfique
toile ou en tout cas et avec ses 6000
euros
vous avez pu avoir une enveloppe globale
à la cantine et la somme exacte on va
acquérir le logement ça fait combien de
temps que là ça fait cinq ans
précisément cette année on est là dans
un bon petit coin parmi tous les amis
qu'aider à l'enduro bcv tout est bon
donc c'est très bien conduit
[Musique]
faux prétendre à ce dispositif il faut
que le candidat à l'aide soit locataire
dans un parc appartenant à l'un des
bailleurs suivant c'est-à-dire es sider
et ça chez les mères cemac ou semader ce
sont ces bailleurs qui ont passé une
convention avec le département danseuse
dans ce cadre là ensuite les autres
critères à prendre en compte sont des
critères de ressources et la qualité de
primo-accédants pour le demandeur
sachant que l'aide qui est attribuée
vise essentiellement les locataires mais
aussi les ayants droit
les dossiers de subventions sont
réalisés auprès des bailleurs sociaux
ils sont ensuite transmis à la direction
de l'habitat
ça change beaucoup on est propriétaire
on peut améliorer les choses ça me
convient pas on est encore à l'heure ça
ne convient pas en tomber
on peut faire les ouvertures on peut
faire d'un arrondissement
on peut faire beaucoup de choses qui se
terminent donc à tempe et on peut pas
tout fait a donc fait à nous on peut
faire un sport vus wet est bien celle du
port
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non